Security is not
an easy subject,
and the issues we
covered in this lesson
are not sufficiently fixable
on just the front end.
Your back end, whatever it is,
needs to implement validation
as well to be properly
secured against CSRF
and cross-site
scripting attacks.
What you have
learned here is how
to spot potential
vulnerabilities,
and how to verify if
they are exploitable.
Whenever you are about to
add any kind of input field
in your web app, you
should immediately
start thinking about
cross-site scripting and CSRF,
and whether there are
potential risks that
need to be mitigated.
You'll do yourself and
your users a big favor.